at the novi yari lovechi border crossing
it's business as usual
about a thousand people transit through
here every day going to and coming from
belarus
on the other side russian belarus are
holding joint military exercises but no
sign of that here
still the border guards say they aren't
high alert and prepared
but how
the last
it depends on the forces which will
oppose us and on the situation we will
face the only thing i can say is that
there are units ready to react in case
of any threat coming from the
neighboring country
there's little to show in terms of
military buildup on the ukrainian side
of the crossing
this ditch was dug a while ago it's now
being reinforced with coils of razor
wire
this road is more than 2 000 kilometers
long it starts in odessa on the black
sea
goes to kiev towards the north of the
country
crosses belarus and ends up in san
petersburg in russia so should russia
decide to send its troops across the
border into ukraine from belarus this
would be a perfect way in
from here it's an easy four hours drive
south to the capital
but at the moment it's ukrainian troops
who are on the move north
ukraine's northern border is more than a
thousand kilometers long
when there were no demarcations russia
belarus and ukraine were all part of the
soviet union
he says his life was better then
his wife nadya is suspicious of us and
says that no one here will tell us what
they really think
people here closely linked to russia
valerie petrovich tells us people
intermarry go shopping across the border
that's where he got his boots
and he doesn't see their big neighbor as
the enemy
no no no no nobody will fight everyone
here will laugh about it we don't care
i watch tv and it's horrible our troops
are mobilizing mobilizing russians don't
care
let them come we will welcome them they
won't do anything to us we are not
afraid because we are part of russia
if they were to invade russians could
also come through the sinkifka crossing
it sits at the junction of ukraine
belarus to the west and russia to the
east
the three sisters monument
a symbol of brighter days between the
three countries
anatoly and his wife are on the way to
visit their daughter and grandchildren
in moscow
they don't go as often because of the
uncertainty of a looming war
but he like most people living near the
border
don't agree or see why relations between
kiev and moscow have reached such a low
point
abdul hamid jazeera along ukraine's
northern border